[Music]
all equines a house to take the crown no
Mariah and Alexis you are kind of
getting introduced to an evolved drag
race audience the show has grown
exponentially since your original
seasons on the show how do you feel
about coming back and being a new girl
to some of these viewers yeah it's crazy
because some of these people were
actually in elementary school when we
were competing on season three so that
is kind of nuts but I'm up for the
challenge and I think that what I have
to offer and from season three is just
classic Mariah but 2.0 it's all about
showing who you are feeling confident
yourself and not apologizing for it for
real we were just talking about this
before about when me and Mariah were on
the season we still on MySpace
picture MySpace you know so Facebook was
not as big and Instagram was not not
even in the plans so everything changes
so much in this latest years you know
when we walk in into social media era
and it has been incredible on me I am
very excited to introduce myself to the
plans of my daughter Vanessa Mandy did
van G give you any advice on how to
handle drag race in this era like it's
kind of strange to it's like what came
first the chicken or the egg book that
is judo do not lion
I remember when I was in my house and I
was preparing him for the competition I
was doing the training you know also you
gonna do this together this gonna walk
like this gonna stay this gonna act like
this so when he find out that I will
found the show it was backwards kind of
like he was like oh girl I know how you
okay so now the the daughter trains the
mother's situation I was it was super
fun with out with Vanessa but um it's
yeah she she knows it all and she was
very blessed to be a very one of the
favorite girls on drag race and still is
and I'm most I'm so proud of her I'm
always just get quiet listen and I
always roll my eyes like I'm gonna just
do whatever the hell I feel like let her
just talk occupy no but it's been a
great learning experience for me I love
it the student has become the master but
a whole new generation is gonna learn
about the power of Bam Bam Bam Bam
[Music]